[Music]
okay here we go
previously on louder with crowder world
how about is it out there bernard hodge
it seems that the youtube algorithm has
advanced beyond all comprehension
they're evolving at a rate beyond their
program and it extends well beyond the
trending and modernization
but now suggested fees and it seems to
even be
targeting subscribers themselves
damn it bernard hodge what are you
trying to tell me
i'm saying that people need to hit the
notification bell now if they want to
see your content at all and more clear
might be more necessary than ever
because
youtube has become a liberal show
you say this like it's a bad thing what
youtube's algorithms are here to protect
you they're perfect
a progression if you will
oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
appropriate
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to cultural appropriation
month
[Music]
uh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
is
[Music]
delicious yeah fantastic uh glad to be
with you tomorrow cultural appropriation
month italy can't believe we didn't do
italy really no you did not do italy is
this the eighth year or ninth year
is it i think we're going to stop
cultural appropriation months after year
10. are we okay just because there are
no more countries it's 10. they come up
with different reasons for us to make
fun of them yeah i guess so
i mean but we've done like california we
could do new jersey or new york
now we'll step at ten
we just said italy yeah
um yes exactly yeah why would we do it's
like we could do hoboken
yeah
um
speaking of things to make fun of aoc
may run for president isn't that great
please uh and we have of course you
heard the testimony yesterday the
january why have i not been addressing
the january 6th
committee hearing theater uh world
premiere
because there's nothing there okay so
now the darling of the left uh [ __ ]
cassidy she is uh up there and we'll
talk about this say her testimony where
she was saying that donald trump did
this in the car and tried to
and it's immediately verifiably false
but that doesn't stop the media from
running with it this is the problem and
i shouldn't say verifiably false i
should say it's he said uh it's he said
[ __ ] set that's where we are right now
and by the way uh which cassidy also
said that donald trump did these
horrible things before she wanted to
have a job with him again again
[Laughter]
it's like colin kaeper colin kaepernick
applying for slavery yeah absolutely so
are we talking about that we'll be
talking about nato finland and sweden
want to join nato uh
i wouldn't let him
and i guess that's mike well you know
we'll get to the question today with
each uh each segment and then of course
elmo got his covet vaccine oh finally
and the shakes the johnson and johnson
[Laughter]
my heart hurts ammo tastes pennies
so gerald the best band the better man
just don't ask him about preeclampsia
it's okay you go we we corrected it live
on air but people will never let you
like no they won't i totally confused it
you still gave some life-saving advice
and then uh he is uh the fastest man on
his feet and we are on tour in the fall
the rebels with a cause comedy tour loud
earthquaker.com tour and it has kicked
off
september 16th in arizona the federal
theater in houston september 17th at the
smart financial center so those are the
first two dates boom so get your tickets
now the rest of them you know it's each
month we do uh at least one or two dates
in the fall dave landau how are you oh
good how about you what was that ahoy i
i half coughed i think okay
i do you don't even know what it was no
i'm scared now i'm gonna i should see my
that was your soul leaving your body
yeah i know
rabbit i just lost 21 grams yes
why was that a crap film oh i know
it's the weight of the soul i don't know
i'm leaving the theater yeah it's like
it's the weight of the soul no it's
actually a dehydration that occurs to
you well shut up that's not a good title
yeah i think it's just allergies that's
what it was yeah yeah i don't know what
that was let me try that again ahoy how
are you i'm doing fine here we are but
uh i'm doing better now that we get to
address uh ao so aoc was on stephen
colbert
yes this was yesterday and we're going
to go through some of the claims versus
the truth of what she made she's trying
to claim that with the supreme court uh
that basically we're looking at
overturning the idea that interracial
marriage is legal she even goes as far
back as the emancipation proclamation
and gets some dates wrong
but we'll get to that before
she is begged by mr colbert to uh run
for president which we will address but
this is this is just an example again we
see what's happening right now where the
media wants to give a platform to
something that really shouldn't be given
a plan i'm not saying she shouldn't be
given a platform
but this idea that we need to rehash and
go through the supreme court ruling
and make up things that just aren't true
this is how they gin up riots and then
of course encourage the riots to
continue as kamala harris did as maxine
waters did as we saw with the black
lives matter riots as we just saw again
with maxine waters right now this is how
you inspire the riots and then of course
the left unlike donald trump through
their direct words called people to
action with the riot so my question to
you is uh do you want aoc to run for
president okay
don't just be just take some time to
process it think it through because your
initial answer of uh may not be correct
so let's get to
the first claim that aoc
uh makes here on stephen colbert's show
she's compared the uh the dobbs
decision to the pre-civil war court's
ruling
on dred scott versus sanford here we go
what what actions
you know do you would you like to see
from your fellow lawmakers because the
court's response to that might be alito
specifically says return this to the
elected representatives of the people
um that where they he believes that
that's where legitimacy at least the the
the issues of rove of abortion should be
returned to the people what action would
you like to see the congress take yes
miss west side story score really
informs a lot um and it gives us lessons
here because this is not the first time
that this has happened uh in the 1800s
the supreme court was taken over
by the confederate south and were
starting to
rule in ways that limited abraham
lincoln for example in the dred scott
ruling they ruled that black americans
are not and can never be full citizens
united states and what did abraham
lincoln do he signed the emancipation
proclamation
he ignored
the gross overreach and abuse of power
during
franklin delano roosevelt's uh attempt
to to restore the country during the
great depression and with the green new
deal i mean that's a great new deal the
new deal
narcissus narcissistic slip
with the new deal um what we saw sorry
just a slip of the sociopath supreme
court attempting to to prevent us from
can't believe this is late
and franklin delano roosevelt threatened
to expand the court
and in his adoption of that position
despite the fact that congress didn't do
it at that time although lincoln did um
the the fear
of the court's power being
minimized caused them to back off their
overreach and abusive power so i know
it's pretty tough where i'm gonna have
to hit you with uh the truth because she
was nonsensical but first off uh gerald
a you had a very i had a couple of
points here i just want to give you a
timeline 1857 dred scott decision 1861
lincoln takes office 1863 emancipation
proclamation that's why i said wrong his
response to this was not the
emancipation proclamation
that was to start a war right
he had other aims in mind by the way the
13th and 14th amendment took care of
that ruling and you know what lincoln
said he's actually quoted as saying this
it would have been helpful if her
researchers had maybe read three
paragraphs more about this decision yeah
lincoln said
offered no resistance to this decision
he thought that the united states system
was so robust that the courts could be
corrected and it was not worth getting
rid of them just because you didn't like
the decision unfortunately you know it
wasn't as robust the back of his head no
oh
now large hats but apparently couldn't
fit a little bit of kevlar so back then
headshot took a while to die yes
uh also here's here's another truth that
you guys know the ruling in scott versus
sanford was wrong because it removed
life and liberty without due process and
like gerald just said the 13th 14th
amendments uh protected against him yeah
and the decision by the way was awful it
was overturned
just like row
just like row that's what's important to
note it's not legislating from the bench
it's interpreting
and hopefully you're an originalist a
constitutionalist interpreting the
constitution it's not creating new
rights that don't exist it's not
creating new laws that shouldn't exist
constitutionally that is not the job of
the court
and by the way
i think one could argue
that killing an unborn baby
isn't so different from forced
i i would almost argue that it's uh in
some ways in some ways worse right it's
really interesting that the example she
gives in taney's majority opinion he
said that african
african people were property their
entire argument rests on a child in the
womb not being a person right it's it's
a black person on my farm yeah
or a bla or a black child in the womb is
either way you're saying that it's your
property exactly it's a separate what
you want that's exactly the argument
they're making is what slaveholders said
it's my property i get to do with it
what i want right
do you really want to be making that
argument aoc right it's like a jg
wentworth commercial for slavery it's my
slave and i need him now
keep someone in a viking hat called jg
wentworth
i'll be honest that's the third time
i've tried to watch that clip and i
can't get past the fourth word maybe no
i i just zone out i think you do it the
resemblance to carson in early letterman
uncanny they're just flying by the seat
of your pants is fun yeah i know
think about it dick cavett was thought
of as being more subdued the thinking
man sort of late night yes and it's
still way funnier than stephen colbert's
way better
well actually i like to kevin but dick
have it came off genuine yeah his style
of interviewing right stephen colbert is
an improviser from the second city
doing what whatever this is now uh
sucking yeah so
here is uh another claim that aoc makes
let's just rattle these off and by the
way all references are available at
lighteroscrider.com she suggested that
packing the court would be a good idea
even though she just in what you just
heard her say right because they were
concerning it with slaves yes yes
[Laughter]
she prefers the term lesser people i'm
sorry yeah lesser people property just a
bunch of baby slaves
oh i think i found a loophole yay
yeah i don't understand why are these
cotton fields look like a cabbage patch
commercial take a picture of me looking
at them sad
you know what never mind i'll just do it
outside of my apartment you can edit
them in that's fine green screen let's
go yes
the only person who's organic photo ops
required peter jackson no
[Laughter]
and she's a frightener she suggested
even though she just said that because
they were concerned about the power of
the court being minimized they decided
not to she then goes on to say she says
let's pack the court meaning expand the
court to minimize its power um what we
saw was an overreach um from the supreme
court attempting to to prevent us from
passing these laws and franklin delano
roosevelt threatened to expand the court
and in his adoption of that position
despite the fact that congress didn't do
it at that time although lincoln did um
the the fear
of the court's power being
minimized caused them to back off their
overreach and abuse of power i believe
that president biden
should entertain expansion of the
supreme court i believe
that
wonderful time in america
it's so stupid
take off your shirt
[Laughter]
stop yelling that
it's just biting
my name sorry and i saw a shirt
that i didn't like
yeah just because
it's him and hunter yeah it's the eighth
time we've told you guys right
hunter's puts away his crack pipe all
right i remember back in the day when we
used to be able to smoke on planes
now i can't even have a little bit of
crack with a late night show come on all
right mr crowd animator so i can still
smell crack on my plane that china
bought me right
you have any ideas how many times i
smoked it on the epstein express so
that's what she said here's here's the
truth okay uh abraham lincoln republican
by the way added a new circuit court and
a new justice to ensure that he could
prosecute a war
against the south
now
it's also important to know yes it is
true that the numbers of the justices
changed early on in this country yeah
here's give me when was the last time we
did it was it
1869
1870 something the last time we changed
the number of supreme court justices
someone just get that to me 30 seconds
or less please and uh it's i'm
in the 60s or 70s 1800s um
the reason that they changed it is
because keep in mind this was a country
that was growing yeah this was a country
that had a population that changed
dramatically and back then travel was a
lot more complicated so it really
related to the circuit courts and once
they said okay this is too difficult for
them to have these meetings this these
amount of times per year so this is how
we're going to do the supreme court this
is the number of people we believe this
is appropriate it has now been since the
1800s that we have stayed with that
number
that's important to note yeah and her
reference to roosevelt is like a
five-year-old saying well he did it too
why am i getting in trouble roosevelt
had a bad idea he threatened the court
so that he could manipulate a branch of
government and here's what's unsaid
there independent here's what's unsaid
there she's saying and uh you know
before he was he was opposed even when
he tried to okay franklin delano by the
way wheelchair guy
and delano
not from a tree though um he uh had a
super majority super majorities in
congress and still so who was it who
opposed him
let's be clear just like when barack
obama was president for the first year
he could have done anything that he
wanted there were enough democrats
opposing him history often forgets that
she wants you to believe that it was fdr
saying let's expand the court and
republicans being
no no it was democrats saying if you do
this we're going to put you in a in a
worse wheelchair
in a straw wheelchair which they didn't
even have yet
they're just showing a prototype right
exactly
see this thing just a rod iron yeah just
one struck next to the wheels don't get
near the grand canyon you got to blow
real hard to get those to move be like
stephen hawking except he's morsing
[Laughter]
what do you say he said your mother's a
[ __ ] oh okay well are you sure
so that was 1863 by the way 1863 okay i
was right within striking distance
here's uh truth number two i think we
have all referenced the bill at
lawrence.com the dobbs decision actually
uh removed power from the court we're
talking about this now this is
this is something here that again and
and i'll get some people give me flack i
know that we are constitutional republic
we're a representative or public i've
said that many many many times i'm using
the democrats arguments against them
where they say this is how democracy
dies now we are not a pure democracy and
with good reason pure democracy is mob
rule that being said if you understand
federalism
you have to recognize the difference
where roe v wade was legislating from
the bench where it became a federal
issue where they were able to regulate
an issue that was not enumerated in the
powers of the constitution bill of
rights now this decision said
we're removing power from the court
that's all this decision is think about
that for a second that's a big deal yeah
it's very rare that you have in
government a government entity say you
know what we shouldn't have control over
this can you imagine the fed saying that
uh you know what we shouldn't be
manipulating currency we were just you
know we're gonna you get you guys are
right let's go back to a gold state of
course not the court said here's what
we're going to do this was bad law
we're going to step out and let you your
your democratically elected
representatives in your states deal with
this
that's it
yeah
you should love that by the way and you
know abraham lincoln had a thought on
this he said they don't love it the
reason they don't love it sorry and i
want you to go on the reason they don't
love it is because they are everything
like you see with andrew breitbart he
said they are everything they accuse you
of being yeah someone who says you're an
authoritarian fascist and then you say
all right well look at least we can take
this step here where we can give more
power to the state so it's not no no no
no no we now need to change our
institutions which by the way you must
trust
in order to remove the democratic
process which exists at a state level
that's where the democratic process
exists right you democratically elect
your state representatives you
democratically elect your
representatives and then they're
supposed to
uphold the constitution and rule of law
it's a safeguard people who call you an
authoritarian as aoc has done
who want to remove
the autonomy from the states they're
simply trying to accuse you of being
exactly what they are guess what
authoritarianism is exclusive to the
left people try and they try and act
this political spectrum
hitler was right wing
how
because he was racist oh and you've
tried to paint republicans and you've
tried to paint conservatives as a racist
that's your only connection big
government
more control over the banks disarming a
select a portion of the populace
authoritarianism is inherently left-wing
certainly in the american spectrum of
politics sorry gerald you had a quote
well no and i wanted to actually say
this like the supreme court is supposed
to be the final word the other thing is
the amendment process right now
two-thirds vote by both houses of
congress and you've got an amendment and
then you have to get three-quarters of
each state to vote the state's
legislators if it's that popular go
through that process don't blow up the
government don't have biden write an
executive order which he does not have
the authority to do to put something
like this into place and here's the
thing abraham lincoln said the court
doesn't establish precedent this is his
thought on it unless it was a unanimous
decision and even then it can still be
overturned by the amendment process
right this was a 7-2 decision when roe v
wade was announced it wasn't a right
before 1963 or 73 sorry and after it was
7-2 it was still split right this isn't
like stuff got written in stone and all
of a sudden the supreme court came along
and said look this doesn't exist anymore
that's not what happened no it was never
in there to begin with that was the
problem you're right though it's the it
is the party of projection yeah yeah and
just the times where it's like you
you're just called a fascist and you're
like you know how far i am from that
right the spectrum of my beliefs right
you want everything ran like this is one
giant prison camp right say i want the
complete opposite when it's involved
with government control no your abs and
think about let's just talk about you
talk about the uh the process okay
i think i can say this on youtube
because they changed their election law
their voting laws in pennsylvania right
it was deemed that it was in fact a
violation of the pennsylvania i believe
it was the pennsylvania supreme court
yeah it was the pennsylvania of their
higher courts i don't know the
constitution that had that it was a
pennsylvania sorry the pennsylvania
constitution and the supreme court yeah
said it is a violation of it but they
said but at this point the damage is
done so whatever so what they want you
when they say you're an authoritarian by
the way uh our people we're going to
allow we want to change the laws without
going through the process violating the
constitution by the way we're going to
ban you if you speak out against it and
say that's foul play
every step of the way every step of the
way we change the laws how we want we
pack the court executive order we
violate the state constitution and by
the way if you question us we're going
to create policy that labels you
misinformation or just gets you removed
you're an authoritarian you know what i
want aoc to speak as much as humanly
possible i will buy that [ __ ] the most
expensive megaphone money can buy
i do want to see your run
you know run run run
run lola
run lola but i was trying to remember if
i remember that was it run lola run it
is running a little low run it's
probably closer to run ronnie run yes
yeah it's true
[Laughter]
run run rudolph because because she's
because she's lying so much she's like
rudolph like pinocchio get it guys yeah
yeah yeah cause she looks like an animal
like a deer yeah so it's with her eyes
it's like she's caught in the headlights
yeah
all right
here's her next claim griffin yeah
everybody was rapping
hit a toilet flush sound this is riffing
in the morning
with crowder and the
clock you wonder why no one listens to
radio or watches cable news
or
news so
she already hit the claim button she uh
uh made the claim that um
we need to abolish this is again these
are these are democratic yes views
protect the court yeah yes ban speech
that we don't like
abolish the filibuster which is a check
and balance so that democrats can do
whatever they want
i believe that he should forcefully come
out in ending the filibuster of the
united states
i believe that he should call on
congress to repeal the hyde amendment
and
i also believe that congress we have the
possib we have the possibility
when we are strengthened by the repeal
of the filibuster or even the change to
a talking filibuster or a standing
filibuster
in doing so we can codify a row we can
codify and all of the other cases that
the supreme court indicated that they
would threaten we can codify same-sex
marriage we can codify the right to
contraception we can codify interracial
marriage we can do it
but we can only do it
we can only do it if we're not fighting
with one hand tied behind our but our
back let alone two and so i think that
right now we just need a fight we need a
fight and we need to show and
demonstrate to the american people that
there will be a vote to give democrats
power we will use it to the fullest
extent possible to defend everybody's
civil economic and human rights okay so
look at that that was very very similar
to what you would hear and i'm not
misusing this
a speech from hitler she just changed it
with to defend the rights what did she
just say uh codify interracial marriage
that's already a thing uh
codify the right to contraception which
really means that you will pay for
contraception and by the way that will
include abortions that because that's
how that's how they view it and then she
just said we need to use the full power
of the de of the democratic party so
that we get not defend what the people
want what
we
want
keep in mind we just had a poll that
came out today i think it's reuters ipso
so you guys can bring it up five to one
five to one democrats support access to
uh transitional
therapies for children who are
transgender five to one when you poll
democrats seriously they overwhelmingly
support it remember when we told you
this was going to affect kids and i had
a transgender mayor from here in texas
say that's a straw man here we are so
when she just said use the full power we
need to pack the court meaning remove
that check and balance we need to end
the filibuster
so that we can defend your rights oh and
by that we mean you pay for abortions
and uh you better give your kids
estrogen therapy or allow them to go
through sex changes otherwise we're
going to take them away that is so
similar to
the speech that you've heard across
history from every authoritarian
dictator ever now here's the truth
hold your nose in googlies because here
comes the cold water aoc the reason that
you're not going to end the filibuster
is because even the democrats don't want
it look it was during i think the two
2019 to 2020 congressional term alone
dems they filibustered 328 times geez
since 2019 filibusters been used by
democrats 657 to republican 609 2009 on
that right
i said 19. i just wanted to make sure i
don't want no more admonishing no sorry
2019 to 20 meaning that 1920
congressional term
320-something times
since 2009
it's a different number now
657 times compared to republican 609 you
by the way guess that longest longest
filibuster in history was performed by
strom thurman who was a democrat against
the civil rights act and i know you'll
say then he became a republican he
became a republican when he realized
that he was wrong about racism if you
look at the longest filibusters
throughout history you can look at how
democrats have used it how they've
abused it this is something the
democrats don't have enough votes from
their own people because they have used
it more they just don't like it when
it's used against them do you know how i
know do you know how i know dave take a
guess do you know how i know well you
know let's levar burton this [ __ ] you
don't have to take my word for it
the american people want less
partisanship in this town but everyone
in this chamber knows that if the
majority chooses to end the filibuster
if they choose to change the rules and
put an end to democratic debate
then the fighting and the bitterness and
the gridlock will only get worse
at its core the filibusters have not
spout not about stopping a nominee or a
bill it's about compromise and
moderation that's why the founders put
unlimited debate in
that's what it's about who is that some
other guy engendering compromise free
hair plugs huh
in moderation it's weird it's so hard
for me to even do this today
they don't even believe what they're
saying they know 12 years before he died
they know that in 2005 video cameras
existed correct and microphones
i don't think they did i don't think
they were aware of the internet until
like a year ago what do they think they
thought c-span was just some flintstones
petrodactyl with like a stone like a
mortar and pestle but
this guy sucks
i think they were relying on the fact
that no one was watching us yeah yeah
or that somebody couldn't pull a clip
from archives it's not like this was
1940
what are you talking about and here's
another truth just to make uh sure that
we're clear uh the loving versus
virginia
case ruled that laws against interracial
marriage were unconstitutional again
under the equal protection clause of the
14th amendment the equal protection
clause to be clear the equal protection
clause
has nothing to do with privacy
roe v wade said abortion which isn't a
right they said well it's because of the
right to privacy between a woman and her
doctor
okay
the reason that interracial marriage was
recognized sure the 14th amendment
sometimes these amendments have
more than one item listed
is the equal protection clause
not the privacy clause
it's not the same thing so when they try
to tell you that it's the same thing
therefore give me all your power and
your money that's really what the bumper
sticker should read used to be from
democrats give me all your money now
it's give me all your money all your
autonomy and all your institutions yeah
and by the way ginsberg felt the same
way she felt like roe couldn't stand on
the privacy clause it just wasn't going
to hold up long term she she wanted it
there and she didn't think that was
going to happen i mean it's a good point
after we just watched a racially mixed
president speak yes
he's mostly irish ah
yes they're talking about just a
commercial donald trump is an
authoritarian they're doing this january
6th thing right nonstop non-stop nonstop
by the way here bring this right up here
on cnn right now
bombshell to have access to the capitol
grounds [ __ ] cassidy we'll get to
the white jesse smell it yeah it's weird
the white jesse smell it i'm poppy [ __ ]
cassidy and the sundance kid you can't
say the other word so here's the thing
donald trump we're gonna spend all of
his time on january 6. he's a he's an
authoritarian okay let me ask you guys
and these are rhetorical but play along
with me a little bit uh did donald trump
want to pack the court did he want to
add seats no okay did donald trump want
to do away with the filibuster no even
though it was used more okay um did
donald trump want to do away with the
electoral college no no no
when donald trump would call out fake
news
did he want people with opinions that he
didn't like to be banned from youtube
twitter facebook
no i bet he wishes when i got rid of
that electoral college now though yeah
that wouldn't have made a difference no
i just toss in a few million votes
safely and securely securely safe votes
that are secured in a fraudulent box
completely alive voters yes a lot of
alive dead voters yes exactly they just
found it in davey's foot locker
intersections are people too i mean it's
just a bunch of votes that they hid in
an actual footlong yes
look there's still one of these yes the
other votes are in a radio shack go
there um
finally to end this segment and i want
to know if you agree with uh with
colbert here um you guys can comment
below colbert and again late night
great
comedy coming evening
[Laughter]
got down on his hands and knees
basically to beg aoc
to run for
um
presidentis
you know there's some speculation as to
whether president biden is going to run
in 2024 there's some there's some
reports he's a little frustrated that
people keep asking because he keeps on
saying yes and people go are you sure
are you sure
um you know uh i know somebody who's
going to turn 35. uh about a month
before the election in 2024
and uh they represent new york fourteen
uh she's actually looking forward to it
um i think that theoretically uh listen
i think that we need to focus on keeping
a democracy
for anybody to be professionals by
removing all of our institutions
that's my central focus is helping the
people of this country so it's possible
so it's possible i don't know about it
[Applause]
i'm just
[Applause]
she misspoke she meant to say i don't
really know about all anything
so um
this is uh stephen colbert asking her to
run for president and this is where
we've come to the point where uh uh late
night comedy host entertainers are
really trying to uh affect and
manipulate the political process yes i
really didn't want to have to do this
but at this point i feel like i have to
yeah um so i want to be clear as to
where i line up
it's
[Music]
important please please please yes
absolutely run for president aoc do it
do please do it do it do it do it do it
do it i will campaign for you oh
tomorrow please
[Music]
i think that's clear yeah and good it's
good
we'll get that to her i wish i may i
wish i might
have
decided for president tonight when you
wish upon a googly eye
[Laughter]
all the food to the you know those
little meetings they stay stay late in
session and all these people have these
special dietary of course like i'm
gluten free oh i'm a pescetarian she's
just like just bring a salt lick yeah
we're doing animals right now with my
son when he sees her he points and says
nay yeah
no he's filibustering at a young age
she's very astute she just says please
rub peanut butter on my gum so i can
talk yeah that's what horses say to my
son that's the sound they make
the scotus rules states can prosecute
crimes on native american lands oh
that's actually good that is fantastic
sorry i mean i'm not gonna lie i'm
really glad that that didn't happen in
1993 when they were hosting the early
ufcs because oh boy but uh yeah i don't
you know
it's i'm sorry
you're a conquered people
we gave you land you just yeah you just
kiss like we'll have our own police yeah
we've seen how that's worked out it's
just no people it's just
meth
they die on the rez this is like the
whole premise of yellowstone yeah
i mean you got a lot of money back yeah
come on a lot of my money back right yes
a lot when's enough enough by the way
your therapy session is i need your mind
and your mind is two today
good
ok where else where else is this a thing
think about it where else do people
win
wars and then give people land and say
oh by the way you don't have to respect
the laws of uh the rest of our land
what
uh i got i got some news you're not
going to like the lane just under this
update it's just
yeah it's it's only if the defendant is
non-native no oh my gosh
that's
wrong
why it's a gray area no that seems like
it's a problem that just seems like
they're going to try and prosecute hate
crimes for every white person who drives
the name so a native so figuratively
speaking
a native american
and for people who are confused
a native american could attack a
non-native
the united states the government of the
united states people could not prosecute
the native american who started the
attack but they could technically hit
the guy who defended himself no no no no
it's it's uh sorry it's states can
prosecute crimes against native
americans committed on reservations if
the defendant is not native so if the
white guy goes on the res
yeah beat somebody right but what i'm
saying saying the other way around what
i'm saying other way around is a white
guy goes there and a native american you
know attacks him and he defends himself
but let's say he accidentally kills a
guy that white guy could still get
manslaughter or that white guy could
still get aggravated assault or battery
whereas the native they just have to
deal with their tribal police which
would be hey come on go drink some
windex and walk it off we'll put you in
the jail this is a teepee right yeah
he's like how did he get out
why would you ever go on a reservation
well if you really want to you know if
you want to know what it's like to live
like drugs the white man only worse
kidding's a joke i guess so and that's
what i mean when they go well the white
man they they're oppressing my land we
should give it back i think hold on a
second since you guys are saying the
white man the native american
reservations it just looks like normal
white people which by the way includes
all non-natives so that would include
black people that would include
asian americans it looks like it just
looks like the crappy area yeah well and
it's the best case study in history for
the government taking care of you and
seeing how that goes giving you land
giving you universal basic income and
saying we'll take care of everything
okay
what has it led to what inventions have
come out of that what advancements in
technology
what advancements took place before the
evil well europeans came over they
didn't use the wheel look look look look
you don't need to know everything else
what do you think happens
when a society that doesn't use the
wheel that absolutely has seen it
accidentally and decided ah we're just
gonna drag this
encounters one with guns
it doesn't mean that evil was not
committed on both sides that means
you're gay
right but let's get let's be honest
that wheel thing looks kind of i say
young man why don't you just roll it
we have the square yes
gonna not ride horses yes yes yes please
stay there i'm busy uh uh scalping
people to prove a point and not riding
horses they just call it the monstrous
bitey thing yeah
we better run all of them off a cliff so
we can eat one i call this aoc yeah
oh i didn't know that oh wow yeah oh wow
i look i i will here's a here you know
here's another deal that i would take we
pay all the rep i don't even know what
reparations we would owe to native
americans pay it all back if the na if
the last native tribes
pay back the other tribes who they
conquered and stole the land so like we
talked about the black hills okay uh
then you should have the lakota pay back
the cheyenne they should pay back the
kiowa i don't know how far back it goes
everyone it just needs to do you
understand that it can't work it just
becomes a domino effect of paying
reparations and at this point
people couldn't even be just because
they're on native land
what it's a silliest thing so i need to
look into this law a little bit more but
i will say uh something that evens the
playing field for everybody is a good
thing because that's inherently
anti-racist can we do native american
cultural appropriation next time
that might be that's tough i think we
did that it's a different country
yes a worse one
within a great one
there's some kind of nice courses that's
all you know some of it's not in
american history you could say
in the in the in the television season
run of american history the native
american era that's just the crappy
flashback episode kind of
yeah i was like well yeah the writers
didn't really want to put a whole lot
into this oh i love this white because
the white man forced me too
yeah go enjoy your android and levi's
shopping mall santa fraud who doesn't
pay taxes not all of you
not all of them
yeah i'm just talking about the people
who try to there's here's the thing
there is nothing there is nothing
stopping you right now native americans
they say we want to go back to there's
nothing stopping you from living off the
land there's nothing stopping you from
living the way that you used to live
you have your own it's been given to you
you pay less for it than everybody else
do you realize there are christian
missions that exist to teach
native american tribesmen how to hunt
and fish
because a good portion of them have no
idea how
do you realize that the
the the white man
from the southern baptist church has to
come in and show you how to paint with
colors of the [ __ ]
all right
well they made that lando lakes uh lady
disappear that's true
yeah i know i used to make her disappear
to this day when you see the butter
you're like i know it's missing you
didn't even replace with it right i know
like put in like a stag wait yeah so you
used to be a lady sitting her stuck yeah
wasn't the problem for removing them in
the first place and now our solution
is removing them again give me back my
butter logo like uh fine first we took
your land then we took your butter sorry
we thought you didn't want it we were
trying to be nice oh that's just white
people's we we love the land of legs
butter [ __ ] if you fold if you folded
up her knees the right way it looked
like tits
crisscrossing that trippy that is true
it's a 100 true 100 yes it is can we
find a picture of oh it is oh you guys
didn't know that trick no i don't know
what that's hilarious
[Laughter]
listen come over here look you fold him
up right looks like her tits yeah
i think mike
comment below this is a generational
thing did you know that if you folded up
the land of lakes and nicaragua has a
whole bit about that too but it's true i
remember learning it when i was it was a
kid who chose me
if you fold up the bottom half the right
way it looks it's like a mad fold and it
looks like she has bare breasts yeah
that was a big deal when we were kids
yeah it was it's hilarious it was like
finding out that if you just went if you
just went backwards and donkey kong you
could skip a level yeah it was that big
of a revelation it's like stephen why
don't we see somebody land the lake's
labels in here
why do you think why do you think the
butter's all on the shelves now nobody's
buying it yeah they're like well no tits
i don't want it i don't even know what
that is
why do all these butters have grooves in
them
uh by the way in case we're still here
on youtube this is a lot if we're not
it's a live show monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern you can watch it on
rumble you can watch it on mug club
today we're actually going to be going
through our our new installment of
dealing with hecklers dave and i from
some of our live shows uh and uh we're
not going to be here you know we'll have
some specials that will be uploaded but
uh you know that month of july is when
we we're actually expanding we're
doubling our studio space yeah so we
have a lot of renovations to make you
might see some changes but unless we
tell you that we're not here
we're always here you can go to rumble
or you can go to my club all right
here's another story that's a lot of fun
see this with elmo
are we we're good to go do you want to
see the land of lakes real quick oh yeah
yeah of course
yes i love it see
you fold it up right all right yeah see
that's right what i don't know no it's
folded up it's the kneecaps
when you fold up the kneecaps it becomes
boobs yeah i used a picture going happy
birthday
mr chieftain
happy birthday that's funny
that's
chad
welcome to my reservations
are you gonna invade me get the hell out
of here ted kennedy oh jeez
he has his car an idol over a bridge all
right
elmo
elmo uh she can swim
it can also call a phone within 19 hours
where were you chad you're covered in
water
wet all right uh elmo everyone's
favorite uh well the puppet not the
pedophile who right had his hand up the
puppet never seen that one coming
uh elmo uh has now been uh vaccinated uh
and there's actually we have this clip
from sesame street
you were super duper today getting your
covert vaccine elmo
there was a little pinch but it was okay
emma was really glad to have daddy and
baby david there with him baby david
where are you
i had a lot of questions about elmo
getting the covert vaccine was it safe
was it the right decision no enough i
talked to our pediatrician so i could
make the right choice who's a commie
i learned that elmo getting vaccinated
is the best way to keep himself this is
a puppet talking to parents by the way
yes healthy and enjoying the things they
love oh daddy oh emma and baby david
have a question
can we have a hug oh come here son uh
everyone loves you daddy but you didn't
get enough hugs from your pedophile
puppets here okay to have questions
about covet vaccines for your kids not
that get the latest facts by speaking to
your pediatrician or healthcare reach
around
well that's what we've been doing to the
pharmaceutical companies for years many
times now here's the thing when i
watched that i originally thought it
sounded like dave doing a voice yeah
but it it wasn't and and here's the
thing we actually and you know they go
through several different cuts with this
with sesame street yes and sometimes we
have we get exclusive information we get
exclusive clips because we have people
who work in the industry and they sort
of send these to us anonymously we
actually have the original
voice over that was intended for that
sesame street vaccine psa oh now daddy
has super duper bandages just like elmo
not exactly son you see you got your
covered vaccine and i got my methadone
yeah elmo's heart is feeding a little
fast right now but it's okay elmo thinks
he needs to go lie down
i had a lot of questions about elmo
getting the covet vaccine was it safe
was it the right decision why do i talk
all black when i look like i'm in smash
mouth the doctor told me i was reading
misinformation and said he knew where i
worked so i told him i'll do whatever
you want just please let me keep feeding
my family
daddy ammo can't move his right arm
anymore
if ammo smells burnt toast oh me too son
get the covet vaccine in all your
children
we even asked the questions
i see they had a bit of a branding issue
yeah yeah i don't know that one seems
more startling said to move off that not
as forceful no
yeah they fired that i don't know if we
have time to hit finland and uh sweden
with nato but i really want to so let me
uh rattle through this quickly with um
[ __ ] cassidy hutchinson
uh
i'm just gonna move on so uh i want to
know if you watch this testimony
and right now everyone is saying amber
heard 2.0 is trending and that's somehow
sexist because they're implying that a
woman might lie on the stand for
personal gain so you can comment below
tool man tell them a comment below uh
here she is the new sweetheart of the
left despite the fact that it was proven
verifiably false almost the moment she
uttered her words
uh bish [ __ ] cassidy
cassidy hutchinson cassidy hutchinson
cassidy hutchinson cassidy hutchinson
cassidy hutchinson cassidy hutchinson
once a top aide to former white house
chief of staff mark meadows cassidy
hutchinson
so um she testified before the january
16th of the select committee oh come on
from the use stop using names they use
it to make it sound like it's really
special just like yeah they really got
away with that with the president's
select the theatrical production i know
i got the high quality yeah it's when
it's cheaper than fanta it's like a gold
card or a hilton right you know it's a
good committee when they have a producer
on staff right
i'm going to stay at the super 8.
so she testified before the january 6
select committee okay uh we're wednesday
so that happened tuesday she was making
second-hand claims about trump she's now
being compared to watergate surprise
witness if you guys remember um yeah
alexander butterfield
all right so let's just go through some
of the claims i wish i didn't have to
address this but unfortunately i do
claim uh number one that she makes she
claimed uh that trump demanded armed
supporters be allowed into the rally
okay
all right here's the truth this is
nothing more than hearsay
she wasn't there for the conversations
and you would know this if you simply
listened to the hearing itself so ms
hutchinson is it your understanding that
mr ornato told the president about
weapons at the rally on the morning of
january 6. that's what mr ronata relayed
to me
oh
[Laughter]
so your best friend's sister's cousin's
friend's boyfriend knows this guy who
saw this person who told this person
that ferris bueller passed out 31
flavors last night
[Music]
[Laughter]
lie
lie
so
here's another claim
that she makes
um the best one
that trump
president then president trump assaulted
did you guys hear me when i said she
wasn't there you guys all heard that
right yeah and you guys all heard when
she said that she wasn't there right it
was called to her by somebody all right
i just want to make sure yeah i i
that's what i said what i heard just
want to make sure because i shouldn't
really have to say anything else no
but i'm gonna so uh she claimed that
president trump assaulted his secret
service agents reached up towards the
front of the vehicle to grab at the
steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and mr when mr
ronato had recounted this story to me he
had motioned towards recounted this
story to me don't you love
okay just hit the truth button don't you
love how detailed that is
for a story that she was told by
somebody else yeah that's how you know
when someone is lying when they're
providing a detailed description of some
this is how you know joe biden was lying
because he didn't just like fib or
exaggerate donald trump was like a
bullshitter where you know donald trump
let's say he's you know
he's like he's a pretty rich guy he's
like at the richest guy a lot of people
say that i'm richer than even you made
richer than anybody a lot of people say
i'm really rich but they say you're rich
they say i'm the biggest rich you know
that he would exaggerate
joe biden would make up stories i'm big
and rich
i'm on tour save a horse
ride me
that's not big and rich's song it
doesn't work without the cowboy a bit
well a lot of people say mine's a better
version
[Laughter]
nobody says that a lot of people do
so
joe biden would tell stories yeah about
people he didn't meet
in places that didn't exist
like amy's diner i go down every day to
amy's diner there is no there's no amy's
diner there's no amy's diner you did not
meet the pope at amy's diner
you did not take a dump in his hat right
at amy's diner and she's sitting there
saying and then no he wanted to grab the
steering wheel lady uh where were his
hands his hands were at 12 and 6.
and he then after taking a deep breath
oh wait a second you're lying yeah
so here's another uh bit of truth for
you she owns one suit
[Laughter]
the story is complete nonsense uh
according to a secret service official
who
i believe was there
uh immediately announced immediately
announced that uh uh ornato denied
telling hudson anything of the sort
there's so much he said she said at this
point and when it's just he said she
said and she wasn't there i believe he
so the secret service also stated that
uh angle a security detail and the
driver are prepared to testify under
oath that neither man was physically
attacked or assaulted and that the
former president never lunged for the
steering wheel so look she wasn't there
immediately upon her making these
statements which by the way cnn is just
they're just now mentioning it happened
immediately and keep in mind they just
ran the story earlier right shocking
testimony now they have as a separate
segment when they know there are fewer
viewers and a much shorter segment by
the way some ex-aids to trump might say
that that wasn't true do you mean people
who were there
people might actually know
also here's something else that it
doesn't necessarily mean she's lying
you can make up your mind i have made up
mine
she was prepared to take a job offer
with trump
after allegedly being told this story
[Laughter]
can you imagine that's an odd odd deal
because if he's so violent you would
want to be around i mean right yeah
he assaulted drivers
i know that these guys are willing to
come out and be like uh yeah that was bs
but let's just think about this all
right think about presidential
protection procedures and the kind of
layout that they have in these cars so
you're telling me that the guys who are
hired to do it right the guys that are
the best in the world that doing this
you're telling me that president trump
in his 70s was able to not reach and
lunge for the steering wheel because
maybe i could buy that he's pissed off
or he's a diet coke can one of the two
also by the way if he's in the back seat
he's mr fantastic that's true or freddie
krueger in the alleyway to reach the
steering wheel because you all know yeah
he's right she said hitting shotgun for
some reason yeah exactly she said he
grabbed his hand off the steering wheel
and said mr president take your hand off
the steering wheel that's not lunging
for it that's grabbing it right so
that's that's something that's a little
often too hand on the steering wheel the
other hand is now reaching for the
throat what is how is he suspending his
body in midair doing that with nothing
to break failed to take into account the
third hand ah yes and that she's lying
so he took viagra that's almost more
pivotal yeah it's true that's a good
point yeah i'm gonna give that one to
you thank you but couldn't you just
think through that one and go
i don't need the secret service to come
out and tell me that you're lying
because your story just told me that you
were lying yeah exactly
believe all women why would we do that
why would we do that i don't believe all
men
people really
people used to swear under oath because
they actually believed in their country
and their god and now you just need such
a mountain of evidence that
it doesn't matter anymore i mean like
you're under oath just lying you know
you're lying oh it's very very hard to
make surgery
like
but like a hundred years ago think about
like in court all you could really rely
on was testimony right that's why the
punishments were severe but yeah i was
there and i tell you that that man he
did he actually reached for the reins to
try and kill somebody and then someone
says well all of us were there and that
lady is a lying [ __ ]
ma'am is this true yes i did lie oh well
to the gallows yeah was it yeah you put
your hand on the bible and she's like
i'm a piece of [ __ ]
you know but i better swear to me
but now it's like you have to have just
so much effort so much i know it's just
it's so apparent that she's lying by the
way to clarify you mean so much evidence
to prove that someone is lying yes yeah
that's a problem you need no evidence to
make the claim no none but so much
evidence to prove it's like well hold on
a second you said this yeah and you
weren't there right and the people who
were more directly involved uh but just
to give you an idea just they have no
moral compass just to give you an idea
too this is this is how we determined
which books to be included in the bible
just to be clear that's how important is
it was the standard of apostolicity am i
saying that correctly i think so yes it
was basically you were there with jesus
or you were in a meet you immediately
were connected to someone who was there
with jesus christ that's why you have
all these other people who were writing
random books they weren't included not
because of some crazy conspiracy that's
why they said okay this is the bible we
are including this because these people
either had direct first-hand accounts or
had close relationships with those who
did and we can verify their we can
verify their stories testament books to
determine which ones got in the 13th
apostle wally is not included right he's
not just always telling lies right like
uh yeah no i was there and uh uh matt
uh matt worked uh he worked at the
sandal store like he was a tax collector
no no i'm pretty sure it was sandals
well that's why when you saw ice cream
yeah yeah what
years later in another country when
other books were found we didn't include
them right exactly you can find random
people trying to capitalize on saying
and he wrote it on on a horse with the
horn and i was like are you trying to
say unicorn yes will that get me a
better book advance shut up that was tom
cruise hey your words not mine yeah
[Laughter]
i'm just asking you if you said it yeah
jesus started arresting people for
future crimes
with metal spiders
and there's one bald [ __ ] kept
screaming
are you just reciting minority report
yes hey you said it pal not me hey
i'm just telling you what happened all
right then he reached for the steering
wheel yeah and the and hit the throat of
a trained professional fighter
the guy charged with and mark wahlberg
if i was in that car it wouldn't have
gone down like that okay okay
all right
so
the new new testament where you're like
this is just i don't even understand
this good vibrations such a sweet
sensation what is this is this the funky
bunch yeah that sounds about right pal
you lost the originals huh
okay and here's the thing it's so silly
and so obviously false yeah
i don't have a problem with a liar lying
i have a problem with people who claim
that they are not liars namely the media
the institutions that you're supposed to
trust
uh immediately
believing this
far-fetched
tale
it's like an asap fable with no moral
so george conway
uh said decades from now people will be
asking each other where were you when
cassidy hutchinson testified yeah cause
it's like 9 11. yeah i don't know doing
anything else that matters i don't know
i might have been doing some dishes yes
yeah or aoc during january 6th i almost
died seven blocks away
are you all right
i'm fine
i am now it was a police officer i
didn't know that yeah i was in upstate
new york during 9 11. he said i was a
police officer
[Laughter]
we all lost something in 9 11. i lost my
class schedule
it's tough
you were in syracuse that's what was it
i just sang we all lost things yeah i'm
just saying yeah
don't say don't tread on my truth that's
not all right i lost a hat so historian
heather richardson
uh wrote hutchinson thinks like i used
to when i was younger you were [ __ ]
she could see it all in her head oh
thanks christopher walken's dead zone
i've lost that gift but i can hold on a
second yeah
this is a historian yes
let me read this again just so you
understand the depths of my disdain for
these people where's she from
yeah
heather richardson she's a historian i
know she's a storm but i want to know
where she works as a historian yeah i
don't know she's like in uh she's she's
she's the national treasure historian
underneath this map is where thomas
jefferson's gold chains are
[Laughter]
i have the gift to see the past yes
but not the present hey can you see the
can you see the future padded room that
that is unclear
so historian heather richardson yeah if
you guys can tell me where she's a
historian she's the uh huffington it's
the magical
factory
yeah exactly all signs point to yes
she wrote
hutchinson thinks like i used to when i
was younger she can see it all in her
head
i've lost that gift but i could
absolutely recognize it in someone else
this is i've ha hi i've lost the gift i
can't
feel the magic anymore
professor of history at boston college
oh
b.c what are you doing all right
i was gonna because she said boston and
i was gonna make a marathon joke but but
i'm not going don't do that i get that
was it it was a her joke well that yeah
maybe the drama from the boston marathon
bombing is what caused her to lose her
game that's true
that's what she just tells her yeah by
the way i should note she's a historian
now she used to be professional oracle
yesterday
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i can't teach you anything
i've lost my gifts
i'm sorry class you're going to have to
just go through your own homework
amongst yourselves and grade your own
papers i have to go dance with a sash in
front of leonidas
and they are going to ravage me if you
want to know history just google it yes
i used to be able to but i've
lost my touch with the keyboard
phd from harvard and she also previously
taught at university of massachusetts
and mit oh wow so she has tainted the
minds of so many people
i can see it
you sound like the i robot
wait if i if i take your class
will it hurt
[Laughter]
what'd yes say i've lost the gift it's
like we're done here yeah we're done
we're done right thanks for admitting it
and by the way retroactively we're going
to remove any and all contributions
you've made to mit harvard
boston
think about this how we talk about
checks and balances
harvard mit
boston college
and no one said no one when she went
through the hiring process or along the
path while she's teaching kids where she
said i can see it all in my head i have
the gifts i'm sorry what
i'm you're lucky i'm here i have to go
find a missing person as i normally do
with police every week just just hand me
the milk cotton blindfolded i'll find
him where's her favorite toy
she's in a well
no that's not me that's aoc you want her
to sniff it and then she'll i see oh
yeah oh it turns out i just have good
smell like a dog yes
well that makes sense considering that
i'm
half dog you know yeah that's why i look
like this heyoc no she's most dog
[Laughter]
she's a reverse canine centaur as we
know them in the hallowed halls of
harvard
all of us have the gifts you see okay
can i read your poem oh you bit me
[Laughter]
when she goes from harvard to boston
college she just rolls in like charles
xavier with a helmet
i hear you'll need a historian
all good we're good i've already got one
staring at a desk trying to lift it for
45 minutes like man what are you doing
in a minute and stop stealing our spoons
[Laughter]
it's not a trick you're just carrying
them to your car
with your brittle liver spotted fingers
those are the spots of my gift leaving
my body just throwing spoons at people i
have a gift
well look if she's lost her gift she's
also lost her judgment because she
thinks that this is a good way to wrap
up
i'm sorry yeah that's right yeah i i'm
just i didn't even get through the whole
quote historian at boston college
heather richardson
hutchinson thinks like i used to when i
was yeah i'm reading the quote for the
third time it's just so funny hutchinson
thinks like i used to when i was younger
she can see it all in her head i've lost
that gift but i can absolutely recognize
it in someone else that's my current
gift
the dripping ketchup story is a dead
giveaway for the accuracy of her memory
she is reliable
[Laughter]
now her new gift is she thinks like jedi
mind trick where she just says it and
like she is
reliable
she is reliable yeah yeah amber heard
is not a [ __ ]
amber herd is not a [ __ ]
she pooped nowhere
you have it
you have the fire starter
oh my gosh
it's terrible i can i can see it the
story with such detail that i
reliable quick hand me the goblet of
liar
i don't need to read any what is this an
apple bomb of the atlantic is that what
i have next yeah the image of cassie
hutchinson age 25 helping the waiter
wipe the ketchup off to off the wall
after the president had thrown it there
will stay with me why why the president
is let's assume that the president threw
ketchup against the wall because he was
pissed is that really the worst crime he
can commit and by the way just to tie in
the uh one flew over the cuckoo's nest
level of insanity remember how insane
aoc was in the previous segment here
here she's reacting on the late show
with uh colbert to understand and see
the detail and the depth through which
there was also just a conscientiousness
of guilt they knew that what they were
doing was wrong when at the very end of
this hearing you hear that mark meadows
the chief of staff to the president
has asked for a pardon because he knew
that he was breaking the law in order to
seize power and undermine democracy in
the united states of america
it is stunning it is absolutely stunning
and the president himself uh was willing
to choke his own secret service oh come
on in order to do so
the detail about that that i like is
that he goes to grab the wheel and this
is how long it's been since he's driven
himself anywhere
he thinks you can drive from the back
seat yeah
he forgot about the pedals yes and all
that should have told you something
stephen you seem like you're on the
right track
i can't believe that was his response
yeah yeah that's awesome she brings upon
the end of time yes
if legend has it that if you see the
left googly eye
you turn to stone
[Laughter]
don't look her right in her left eye
don't wait did you say right or left hey
by the way do you know why those people
were asking for pardons it wasn't
because they broke the law it's because
they were afraid whether it's the left
or right is merely an illusion no you
just choice is not real no sorry go
ahead they were afraid of political
witch hunts yeah i wonder why right i
wonder why they were afraid of political
witch hunts not breaking the law not
something they deserve to go to jail for
political witch-hunts i wonder why
gerald don't be afraid i'm not i use
these gifts for good but you said you
lost it but there's petals
yes as well my gift doesn't encompass
that
mr president i will say my gear from the
bridge is limited to lawnmower engines
or lower
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
i guess we're gonna have to do sweden
and finland joining uh nato tomorrow uh
my answer is no they won in they owe a
few hundred billion dollars in back pay
level up first
yeah no kidding but i hear sweden has
the gift but nope never given us the
gift don't have it they have not given
the gift that's that's the tale as old
as time with me historian
something hutchinson from boston college
long is all this friends it's a song as
old as time is the gift can be wielded
for good or tremendous evil power walks
up to michael moore thinner
[Laughter]
[Applause]
normal eye
nope didn't do it spits in dirt probs it
on her eye ah
they're worse are they are they better
no i just didn't want to look at it yes
[Laughter]
this is
puts her hand
on joe biden's head like she's curing
his brain like phenomenon
[Music]
i'm taking all its degradation into me
i've lost the gift i don't have it i
don't i don't have it it's the same
thing as the alien yes it's like
scanning
the pain the gift it comes with great
pain and responsibilities the gift's not
without its shackles
the gift is back i've never seen things
so clear my eyes are just bleeding
because she'd be a recurring character
what's her name what hutchinson a man
was it amanda hutchinson
heather hutchinson heather heather
heather hutchinson her name is
i don't know heather heather cox
richardson oh heather cox richardson
hutchinson is the [ __ ] cassidy
yeah
all right
let me ask you my final question is do
you also have the gift uh we're going to
go to
the only gift that i want but in a cruel
trick of nature i cannot procure
is more time
this is real i would walk into her class
like a revolving door and walk right out
yeah you just walk in the gift bye-bye
yeah yep no wait i've lost it we need to
do that we need to go there we need to
go to boston college we need to come see
you fellas just dress yeah in a certain
way like kind of like a witch like that
dude yesterday and just be like i want
to talk to you dress like a bottle of
ketchup and walk in the classroom i hear
that you bear
the mark
how'd you know it's just a tattoo she
got in a fruit loop box
how do you know about sam she's refused
first name toucan
because you too can have the gift yes
only you can't really only i have the
gift
but i lost it but i did have a gift
hey lottery if you want more lotto
squatter.com tour is the rebels with a
cause it kicks off me and dave in
phoenix september 16th at the arizona
federal theater that's the big one
and uh then we have houston the very
next day at uh what is houston his smart
financial center in sugar
and i've seen you folks in houston
should be called sugar foot
dave is going to be july 15th 16th
columbus ohio uh the funny bone yes the
funny bone yeah the weekend of july 29th
the funny bone in omaha nebraska and if
you don't mind lapeer michigan july 9th
and we bring you my gift yes and then we
are going to go discuss dealing with
hecklers here on mug club that we cannot
show here because every now and then
someone in the audience
has the gift and youtube my gift to you
is
you will piss off
[Music]